now with shaq barrett it very well could
be that he wants so much that like you
said they just they just know they can't
do it right and we've we've mentioned a
few times how many pass rushers are
hitting the market they can just do what
they did two years ago when they signed
shaq barrett he he comes in as a
stranger and he has 19 sacks no so
they'll find another pass rusher to come
in maybe you can get two or three pass
rushers for less than what it would cost
to keep shaq barrett for a year no i i
mean you're right mike you you made that
point on on text yesterday
and when you said it i went oh
that's a really good point there's i
that that might be part of the equation
you're right with the fact that if he's
asking for some huge you know and what
was his going to be his franchise tag
going 18.99 18.99 million so i don't
know what he's asking for but
there is a lot of guys out there like
you're talking about on the edge
right who
won't be able to command shaquille
barrett type money
and
you know he's a guy again you know he
was a middle round pick if i remember
correctly coming out of colorado state
drafted by denver doing all that he's
just starting to make money so he might
be one of those guys that looks at it
and goes you know listen i love the
bucks and i'd love to be here for a
winter but it's it's time for you know
big daddy here to get paid right he so
he might be one of those that goes i
don't i need the money i want i want
some security some long-term stuff and
all that and that becomes an issue okay
but then yes to your point
you know there's a there's guys out
there like leonard floyd for an example
and and a lot of other players to where
you go wow that's a really good player
that's not going to be able to command
18 million dollars a year or anything in
that ballpark and i i think that makes a
lot of sense and i can see that you know
yannick and gawkway can he command that
kind of money out on the free on the
market i don't think so not at this
point it's a good good chunk of change
and i don't expect it to be him but just
adding to your point there are a lot of
good edge pass rushers out there
and that's what's amazing because we are
reminded from time to time specifically
in the super bowl how important it is to
have great pass rushers and then we kind
of forget about it and then we're
reminded of it again by some dominant
pass rushing performance in the super
bowl so this is a valuable position i
would put quarterback pass rusher tackle
i don't know how do you rank that well
as overall value is it is pass rusher
more valuable than a tackle i think so i
do yes yeah
yeah i think i look at that and just go
a pass rusher an elite pass rusher can
affect the game in so many ways and
tackle of course is very important for
all the reasons to block those guys but
man a really elite defense and you know
they affect the run game they can be
great that way and then of course
the the amount of forget the sacks and
things like that it's the disruption
it's the quarterback pressures
everything that that helps the secondary
so i i would say that's probably the
number two thing on my list too
and that's what makes it amazing that so
many of them are going to be floating
around and that's got to be factoring
into the buccaneers thinking this isn't
something they just randomly did this
isn't just well tommy wants his receiver
here so we have to keep the receiver and
we'll just have to figure something out
on defense defense has to be a priority
their defense has been a key part of
that championship run that defense
helped them in many situations that
defense kept the packers from parlaying
three consecutive tom brady
interceptions into a victory what would
have been a stunning come from behind
victory they were down 28 to 10 green
bay was the defense stiffened on two of
those three drives and kept the packers
from taking the lead and then we know
what happened we have a down at the end
of his prime i assume that was one of
the drives
from uh resulting from one of the
interceptions where they almost uh
scored the the touchdown and didn't go
for it unfortunately didn't go for it on
fourth down yeah so um defense important
but maybe they think they can find
another shaq barrett and not have to pay
that kind of money barrett did say not
that long ago he wants to break the bank
so we know
we know that his objective is to get
paid maximum dollars and to get maximum
dollars he may have to go somewhere i
that that's where when you really look
at it and you hear those comments and
just that that was my first thought like
i said that he might be asking for you
know they realized man it's this is
going to be a one-year thing and he's
out of here because he's looking to
break the bank and listen from shaquille
barrett's standpoint
he can look at other defense ends in
football right now and go
wait
i've been better than these guys for
three years now and they're making a ton
of money and here i'll just throw out
some names i mean he certainly can look
at demarcus lawrence and frank clark who
i you know i got a lot of respect for
frank clark and what he does but he can
look at them realistically and go
wait i i've been better than them for
two or three years now he can look at
trey flowers who went from new england
to the detroit lions who's making 18
million dollars a year and go i'm
definitely better than him there's
there's no doubt about it i so i affect
the game in more areas and do all those
type of things so from that standpoint
you look at it and yeah i look at
shaquille barrett and i'm not mad at him
if he's asking for 20 million dollars a
year north of that for where the market
is and things like that and he's the
next guy up and all of that so uh it'll
be interesting to watch what happens
with them here as we go along
and and you know it's not just looking
at the guys who are going to hit the
market it's considering the guys
who may still yet hit the market von
miller and the broncos have yet to
figure out their situation the broncos
obviously and reportedly want von miller
to take less than 18 million dollars
this year if he hits the market we don't
know what kind of conversations he and
tom brady have been having you know
there's all sorts of tampering that
isn't really tampering that happens
among players the idea of
tom and vaughn
reuniting or uniting they've never been
united before except on opposite sides
of the ball in tampa you know that that
that's just one of the paths that the
buccaneers can take it is and that's
where the challenge becomes forgetting
who the guy is forgetting what he's done
and saying we got to make a good
decision and the other side of this too
and this may be why barrett wants so
much money i mean he knows what else is
out there all it takes is one owner
to to say
i want that guy i want that guy i want
that guy
and you know what his team is going to
pay that guy
and and that that getting that guy who
was part of a super bowl run and making
him the center piece of your free agency
class and also hurting the buccaneers or
thinking you're hurting the buccaneers
that's part of this game too there's a
strong business component the free
agency you know i've seen every every
year at this time we see the articles
and the analyses which point to a
conclusion that we already know you
don't build a championship team in free
agency by spending big money no you do
it by being smart and waiting for the
market to settle and shopping for
bargains but you build a successful
financial operation in part
by
creating excitement by going out and
overpaying a free agent because you get
season ticket renewals you sell jerseys
you take attention away from other
leagues teams and other leagues in your
market there are business reasons for it
to happen that are independent of
whether or not it's ever going to help
you win a super bowl and that's part of
the reality and even in a year with a
reduced cap chris there's going to be
teams that want to make that splash
especially as we recover from the
pandemic we start thinking about selling
tickets for 2021
it helps to sell tickets if you can say
we got shaq barrett away from the tampa
bay buccaneers no no doubt about that
there is that aspect some teams looking
to make a splash just get you know in
the good favor of the the fans get a
little hype and propaganda going about
hey we're doing the right things as an
organization here we're trying to win
and do that and that could very easily
be shaq barrett he would fit that mold
too to where you might not you're not
gonna have to pay him to be the highest
paid defensive end in the history of
football or anything like that but
you're gonna be able to give him a
splash contract and go look you see what
he did did you see all those highlights
of him chasing down the homes and all
over them and did you see all those big
sacks he had against aaron rodgers in
that game yet the guy's big time he
shows up in big moments and that will
excite a fan base to what you're saying
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports